I thought you were asleep.
Ah, well, you also thought I was dead, right?
So I guess this is the thing I do now.
You should have stayed down.
That's right. Man, you f***ing ran me over.
Chill out. Look, whatever he told you, he is
lying, okay? He killed Chloe, and now he's
doing it again. Get her outside.
He's just gonna leave you. She knows too much
. Do his dirty work, and then he's gonna
bail. Just leave you in this haunted moose
lodge. Seeing Chloe everywhere you look.
Are you trying to play us against each other?
We've been friends for years.
Bullsh*t. Okay.
Jimmy? He killed her, you understand?
He killed Chloe.
Oh my God, you b*tch!
This is pathetic, right?
What did you mean? What?
Another chick going crazy on you.
What did you mean?
Don't let her get inside your head right now,
man. Just. Chloe.
Chloe.
Did she go crazy on you?
Dude, you said she had an accident.
A bad reaction to the coke I sold you that
she fell.
That is what happened. She fell.
No, that is bullsh*t.
Did you hit her? Did you push her?
No!
Bullsh*t. Okay, none of this matters.
We were kids.
I mean, who cares?
Jimmy. How long have we known each other?
Think about everything we've been through.
You were always like my big brother.
You're my protector. And now I can return
the favor. You want out of all this, I can
get you out, Jimmy.
Whatever you want, whatever you want.
We just got to do this. One last thing.
Jimmy, please.
All right. There he is.
Let's get her outside. It's cleaner that
way.
No. Okay.
Come on.
Let's just get it back up.
Get out of my way!
You ruined my life.
I ruined your life?
I was the only good thing you had going.
You were a loser then.
Just like you were a loser now look at you,
still stuck in this sh*thole.
Let me tell you a secret.
This is where you were always going to be.
Maybe. But at least I'm done being your
b*tch.
Ah ah.
Uh oh.
Uh. Oh.